Joyeux anniversaire, joyeux anniversaire !
Ne cherchez pas les bougies.
Je suis en train de me laver les mains
à la fontaine du jardin.
Alors, il faut bien frotter partout,
entre les doigts, les ongles,
et ne pas oublier les poignets.
En fait, la peau est recouverte d'une pellicule de graisse
sur laquelle se déposent les microbes,
les bactéries et les virus.
Vous voyez de quoi je veux parler !
Les molécules qui constituent le cerveau
sont extraordinaires.
D'un côté,  elles s'accrochent à la graisse
et de l'autre à l'eau.
Mais comme il y en a davantage,
c'est l'eau qui l'emportent
et qui en s'écoulant arrache toute la saleté.
Y compris les virus... Mais attention !
Pour que ça fonctionne,
l'opération doit durer au moins 20 secondes.
Le temps de chanter 2 fois "joyeux anniversaire".
Alors, vous n'êtes pas obligé de chanter à haute voix,
mais ça fait tellement de bien !
une vraie "capsule de déconfiné"
Allez à demain et vous connaissez la chanson :
nous sommes confinés, mais on reste en lien !
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné" :
abonnez-vous
et activez la petite cloche
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain !